allô allô allô allô bonjour à tous
j'espère que vous allez bien je me
présente moi c'est l'orage juste l'orage
sans
apostrophe la question qu'on m'a posé le
plus souvent en tant qu'auteur
compositeur c'est où est-ce que tu
trouves ton inspiration et on m'a posé
cette question tellement régulièrement
que j'ai vraiment eu le temps d'y
réfléchir
alors on va se dire peut-être que
l'inspiration c'est quelque chose qui
vient de nos émotions on va se dire que
c'est quelque chose qui vient des autres
et on va parler de ça dans ce toc Farel
Williams un grand producteur de musique
américain a dit dans une interview on
aime bien être possessif mais la
créativité elle ne sort pas de nous la
créativité c'est le travail de l'univers
nos cerveaux fonctionneraiit un petit
peu comme des antennes nous permettant
de capter les
idées alors il continue en disant
surtout ne t'arrête jamais de créer
parce que c'est comme si on avait une
carte de bibliothèque pour aller
emprunter des idées gratuitement et de
pas s'en servir alors selon lui ce
serait un petit peu dommage et je suis
assez d'accord avec lui Charles Bukovski
un écrivain américain a écrit un poème
qui s'appelle so you want to be a writer
alors comme ça tu veux être écrit
et dans son poème il dit si ça ne sort
pas de toi comme une explosion ne le
fais pas si ça ne vient pas sans
demander de tes tripes de ta tête de ton
cœur ne le fais pas si tu dois rester
pendant des heures derrière l'écran de
ton ordinateur en forçant les phrases ne
le fais pas alors comme ça ça peut
paraître un petit peu pessimiste on
dirait qu'il essaie de nous dissuader de
nous écarter de de la créativité
mais moi ça m'a toujours motivé alors
j'ai pas osé répondre par ça aux gens
qui m'ont posé la question sur l'INT
pardon la
créativité parce que selon moi tout le
monde peut créer que ce soit une recette
de cuisine que ce soit un livre que ce
soit une chanson et bien selon moi tout
le monde peut créer par contre créer
n'est pas la quête principale de tout le
monde les enfants par exemple vont être
beaucoup plus perméables à l'inspiration
et à la créativité pourquoi et bien
parce qu'ils n'ont pas encore de
croyance limitante qui les bloque dans
leur création ils vont peut-être
dessiner contre un mur un petit bonhomme
en bâton et puis un deuxième et puis
l'appeler ça c'est papa ça c'est maman
pas de jugement les adultes en revanche
et bien on va beaucoup plus se brider
alors certains pour certains ça va
simplement être le côté sérieux de la
vie d'adulte qui va les écarter
de la créativité d'autres vont se dire
je ne suis pas suffisamment bon
talentueux imaginatif
téméraire intelligent même
peut-être et selon moi c'est simplement
que beaucoup ne savent pas par où
commencer alors ça c'est une très bonne
question si on veut créer quelque chose
si on a une idée par où commencer et
bien on va commencer par s'immerger dans
l'art que l'on souhaite créer pour
s'imprégner de ce qu'on aimerait
construire un chanteur par exemple va
écouter énormément de musique un
photographe ira voir des expos suivra
d'autres comptes de photographes sur les
réseaux et va rencontrer d'autres
photographes
euh un scénariste un réalisateur va
regarder énormément de films alors
peut-être que ce sera des classiques
peut-être que ce sera du kubrique du
nlan du scorsz du
Hitchcock mais peut-être aussi que ce
sera des choses qu' qu'il aime moins
pourquoi et bien parce que ça le guidera
vers ce qu'il ne veut pas créer parce
qu'en réalité on peut se nourrir de
tout on peut se nourrir de tout par
contre on peut essayer d'éviter de se
nourrir de ce qui peut être considéré
comme étant de la mauvaise qualité alors
parfois c'est changer de chaîne parfois
c'est changer les réseaux sociaux
peut-être par des livres de la
littérature parfois ça va être changer
les news par des grands reportages et
cetera de la qualité Stephen King
l'écrivain américain a dit un jour si tu
veux devenir écrivain il faut diviser ta
journée de travail en deux
parties 4 heur d'écriture mais 4 heur de
lecture également et non pas seulement
de l'écriture intéressant c'està dire
que même Stephen King aller chercher de
l'inspiration va chercher de
l'inspiration ailleurs et le conseil
d'ailleurs tout ce que l'homme crée il
le crée sur ce qui a déjà été créé
finalement seul une toute petite
partie il y a une idée qui dit que
l'être humain ressemble beaucoup au 10
personnes qu'il côoi le plus alors selon
moi c'est très vrai et selon moi c'est
un petit peu pareil avec l'art parce que
l'art qu'on fait va beaucoup ressembler
à l'art que l'on côtoie le plus
souvenez-vous du poème de
Bukovski si c'est difficile rien que
d'imaginer à commencer ne le fais pas si
tu essayes d'écrire comme quelqu'un de
connu
oublie l'étape suivante ça va être de
faire un brainstorming alors là c'est
génial parce que il y a pas d'erreur
possible c'est notre booket à la idée et
on va essayer de chercher des indices
dans la création une grande partie n'est
pas directement du physique mais bien de
l'intuition du subtil de l'émotionnel
c'est les moments qui vont nous donner
des frisson qui vont nous couper le
souffle qui vont être les ind les
indices qu'on voudra écouter
alors quels indices allons-nous écouter
et
bien il se peut que à un moment
donné certains se trouvent devant un
obstacle qui est assez récurrent dans la
créat ité et c'est la peur de l'infini
la peur de l'illimité bah oui quand on a
une toile blanche vierge et bien tout
est possible on peut théoriquement tout
faire et ça ça fait peur alors la
solution à ça ça va être justement de
consciemment se limiter pour prendre un
exemple personnel quand j'écris des
textes ça m'arrive de prendre trois mots
aléatoires dans le dictionnaire par
exemple et de commencer à partir de là
de les faire rimer par exemple quand je
compose quelque chose je me dis des fois
ok un tempo une longueur cinq
instruments pas un de plus pas un de
moins et ça me permet de canaliser mon
énergie faire un anenton noir et d'aller
de l'avant un très bon exemple de ça
c'est le peintre Yve cllein qui pendant
tout un moment de sa carrière a décidé
de ne travailler qu'avec la couleur
bleue et il en est sorti un des Bleus
qui est considéré comme étant le plus un
des plus beaux bleus du monde qu'on
appelle le bleu de clin qui est très
intéressant si on
se
alors beaucoup d'artistes vont décrire
durant leur processus durant leur
expérimentation un état de flow en
psychologie un état de flow et bien
c'est un état de concentration maximale
quand on va être complètement plongé
dans une activité et là c'est très
agréable c'est là que la magie opère
c'est pour ça que c'est très très
intéressant de
voir les idées
et comme étant des graines pourquoi des
graines et bien parce que certaines vont
germer et d'autres non et c'est
totalement ok on va s'occuper d'abord de
celles qui vont germer pour continuer à
faire germer nos plantes et bien il
faudra un autre ingrédient et c'est pas
de l'eau
c'est pas du soleil mais c'est de la
patience parce que l'art ça ne se force
pas ça m'arrive des fois de me retrouver
devant un projet et d'être complètement
bloqué alors je peux me dire
ok je vais je vais me forcer à le
faire mais ce que j'ai remarqué c'est
que la meilleure chose que je puisse
faire c'est de reculer et d'y revenir
une autre fois dans une autre
énergie et là à un moment ou un autre
j'aurai de nouveau de l'inspiration qui
revient on parle souvent de l'angoisse
de la feuille blanche bien l'angoisse de
la feuille blanche c'est
une c'est une angoisse aussi de peur du
jugement de compétition si on pouvait
enlever tous ces facteurs et bien elle
finirait par disparaître alors certaines
personnes vont préférer supprimer
complètement le facteur de temps alors
que d'autres vont TR mieux sous pression
et ça ça dépend vraiment de chaque
individu par contre ce qui est bien pour
tous les individus de peu importe la
catégorie et bien c'est travailler sur
plusieurs projets en parallèle pourquoi
et bien pour rester stimuler pouvoir
passer d'un à l'autre quand justement on
a ce genre de problème le travail d'un
artiste en grande partie ça va être de
trouver
l'extraordinaire dans l'ordinaire
donc une grande partie de son travail ça
va être de filtrer et de garder
uniquement
l'essentiel quand est-ce
que j'ai terminé mon œuvre souvent on a
tendance à rajouter se dire qu'est-ce
que je pourrais rajouter un dernier coup
de pinceau un dernier chapitre une
dernière mélodie alors qu'en réalité il
faudrait se demander qu'est-ce que je
pourrais enlever pour que ce soit
terminé alors je un certain point c'est
le travail et la répétition qui vont
rendre
parfait comme disait Jacques Brell il y
a pas de talent c'est de la sueur c'est
de la discipline il disait 99 % de
travail 1 % de talent alors je suis 100
% d'accord avec Jacques Brell par contre
une œuvre d'art peut théoriquement être
modifiée à
l'infini et là à un moment donné il faut
savoir
s'arrêter
alors on va toujours essayer d'aller
vers quelque chose de parfait
mais c'est très important de voir une
œuvre l'œuvre d'un artiste comme étant
une photographie à un instant T de la
vie d'un artiste plutôt qu'une œuvre en
perpétuel changement qui doit être rendu
parfaite on va vouloir rendre parfait
alors qu'en réalité dans l'art et
peut-être dans tout ce qu'on fait dans
la vie le but est de faire quelque chose
non pas de parfait mais bien de
parfaitement imparfait bah oui
l'imperfection en fait c'est ce qui va
rendre humain ce que l'homme fait qui va
lui donner une
âme
alors on se retrouve devant notre uvre
et cetera et quand est-ce qu'on a
terminé notre vre et bien on a terminé
notre vre quand on décide qu'il n'y a
plus rien à rajouter qu'il n'y a plus
rien à enlever et qu'on estime qu'elle
est parfaitement
imparfaite dernière étape c'est pas tout
à fait fini et c'est pas la plus facile
et bien ça va être d'oser
partager parce que si on ose pas
partager c'est que la peur de le faire
la peur de la critique et du jugement
est plus grande que le besoin de
partager mais pour progresser et bien il
faut pouvoir lâcher le fardeau le sac à
dos d'une œuvre pour pouvoir laisser de
l'espace à une nouvelle le moment où on
partage l'œuvre ne nous appartient plus
totalement et ça c'est aussi un point en
moins parce que une part de la
responsabilité de cette œuvre est au
monde et plus uniquement à
nous j'aimerais terminer avec un autre
poème de Charles
Bukovski deux
protagonistes le poème s'appelle l'air
le temps la lumière et
l'espace oh mon
vieux que ce soit ma famille que ce soit
mon travail quelque chose s'est toujours
mis en travers mais maintenant j'ai
vendu ma maison j'ai trouvé cet endroit
oh il faut que tu vois ça un grand
studio cet espace cette lumière pour la
première fois de ma vie je vais avoir
une place et le temps de
créer mais non mon vieux si tu dois
créer
tu vas créer en travaillant 16 heur par
jour dans une mine à charbon tu vas
créer avec trois enfants dans une petite
chambre alors que vous êtes au service
social tu vas créer aveugle estropié
dément tu vas créer avec un chat rampant
sur ton dos mon vieux l'air la lumière
le temps l'espace n'ont rien à voir avec
ça il ne crée rien sauf peut-être une
vie plus longue afin de se trouver de
nouvelles excuses
merci à
[Applaudissements]
tous